india prohibió con efecto inmediato las
exportaciones de trigo para controlar el
aumento de los precios de la cosecha en
el país dijo el viernes la dirección
general de comercio exterior india
representa el 13 puntos 53 por ciento de
la producción mundial de trigo lo que lo
convierte en el segundo mayor productor
según la notificación oficial el aumento
repentino los precios mundiales del
trigo que surge de muchos factores hace
que la seguridad alimentaria de la india
los países vecinos y otros países
vulnerables esté en riesgo el texto
precisa además que el gobierno indio
podrá emitir un permiso especial para
exportar trigo a países que estén en
riesgo de sufrir de escasez alimentaria
la demanda de exportación de la india ha
experimentado un aumento este año debido
a la escases de trigo en los mercados
mundiales debido a la guerra entre rusia
y ucrania la decisión de detener el
flujo de trigo para las exportaciones
aparece apenas semanas después de que el
gobierno se mostraba eufórico anunciando
que india alimentará al mundo pero la
decisión se produjo después de que las
adquisiciones para la temporada 2000
22-23 tuvieran dificultades para
alcanzar el objetivo revisado del diseño
de punto 5 millones de toneladas este
objetivo fue casi un 56 por ciento más
bajo que la admisión de admisiones y al
de 44 puntos millones de toneladas en
las últimas semanas muchos países han
pedido trigo a la india mientras que
turquía perdió 50 mil toneladas egipto
que era un millón de toneladas pero con
el aumento de la demanda mundial la
producción de trigo en la india se ha
desplomado en particular debido a las
olas severas el calor desde marzo